this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of medical
images and videos to use in lectures courses
presentations professional training and more
for more information click on the link in the
description mrna vaccines for covid19 vaccines are
substances that protect you from harmful diseases
most vaccines contain parts of weakened or dead
germs that trigger your immune system to fight
the disease but mrna vaccines for covenanting are
different they contain a substance called mrna
that teaches your cells how to make a
protein that triggers an immune response
in order to understand how these vaccines
work it's important to know what mrna is
and how it normally makes proteins your body needs
most cells in your body have a command center
inside them called the nucleus it contains genetic
material called dna that consists of instructions
for building and maintaining your body proteins
are one of the building blocks of your body
when a new body protein needs to be built
instructions for building it are copied from your
cell's dna and converted into a message called
messenger rna or mrna then the mrna travels out
of the nucleus to a protein-building machine in
your cell called a ribosome as the ribosome reads
the message from the mrna it builds the protein
your body needs mrna vaccines take advantage
of this process to help give you immunity to
coven 19. each vaccine contains special mrna
that provides instructions for your cells to build
a harmless piece of the virus called the spike
protein the spike protein is found on the surface
of the sars cov2 coronavirus that causes covid19
each piece of the mrna from the vaccine
is wrapped in a protective coating
the vaccine is given as a shot in the upper arm
in the body the mrna particles enter your cells
once inside the cell the
mrna travels to a ribosome
using the mrna from the vaccine the ribosome makes
only a piece of the spike protein from the virus
after making the piece of the spike protein
your cell destroys the mrna from the vaccine
it's important to know that the mrna from the
vaccine never enters the cell's nucleus or
changes its dna in any way next your cell presents
the piece of the spike protein on its surface
this allows your immune cells to detect the
protein and recognize that it doesn't belong there
as a result your immune cells begin making
antibodies as part of an immune response to
the virus in the future if you catch the virus
the antibodies recognize and attach to the
spike protein pieces on infected cells and the
spike proteins on the virus this marks them for
immediate destruction by other immune cells like
all vaccines the benefit of these mrna vaccines is
that they give vaccinated people protection from
the virus without having to get sick with covet
19. most mrna vaccines for covid19 require
you to get a second shot within a few weeks
sometime after getting the vaccine you may have
symptoms such as a fever this is normal it means
the vaccine is working to make you immune to the
virus vaccines protect you your family and your
community from diseases that can be dangerous
or even deadly for up-to-date information
about vaccines for covet-19 visit the centers for
disease control and prevention website at cdc.gov